empower Eurasian day didn't always  happen in Washington DC the first took  place in 1789 in New York City the  temporary capital of the newly formed  United States  the Constitution originally set  inauguration day to be unmarked forth  it wasn't until 1937 when it was an end  to January 20th the oath of office which  swears in the new president is short  enough to fit on to two tweets  presidents are not required to be sworn  in with a Bible but only two out of 44  presidents have been sworn in without  the shortest inaugural address was  George Washington's at just 135 words  the longest was William Henry Harrison's  at about 8,500 words it lasted almost  two hours